you do have two young kids is that right
I do I do have a son it's three and a
half and a beautiful daughter that's
eight months they're starting to look
into schools then yeah yeah that's a bit
of a that's a thing like in New York and
then really out here in LA that's the
whole thing is schools yeah when I grew
up in Iowa and you went to school where
your school was it was just like here
you go and then you take your little
lunch and you sit in there and and the
and that's it yep and in Los Angeles
it's like a huge to do so I remember
when we you know started doing the
research and you're like well I want
these kids to have the best so we're
gonna go look at a bunch of different
preschools and and I was why it was 2:00
and I was potty training him and it was
big the big drought in California and so
I was teaching him to go on P adventures
where he would say dad I have to pee and
we'd go outside and we'd pee in the
bushes because that saves the
environment right we're saving water
yeah it's also it gets him excited about
peeing not in the diaper and it's
fantastic so we go to this really
beautiful preschool and it looks like a
Restoration Hardware had decorated the
whole place and the woman that's like
running the school has got like that
wonderful indiscriminate accent from
someplace near England she's like hello
how are you how is Wyatt and so I'm
talking with her and I see my son
running around inside this beautiful
like Cathedral looking preschool and he
goes over towards the plants and I'm
watching and like oh God and he starts
to pull his pants down I'm like oh no
he's gonna pee in the preschool but he
doesn't just pull his pants not enough
to get like his peepee out he pulls him
all the way down so my son is sitting
there like buck-naked little white legs
in the white butt and he's peeing in the
plants but he has to leave and he's come
for his interview first this is an
interview for school yes and the woman
I'm talking to you as like $100,000 in
jewelry and she's talking to me about
the school and said you know it's
philosophy on education and my son is
there peeing in the middle of his potted
plants and I'm just like trying to keep
her attention I'm just like asking
questions and trying to get him to
finish but he's over there taking his
time and he's like hitting his peepee on
the plant
I might just wrap it up and finally
pulls his pants up and I'm just like oh
god we made it we're fine and then he
comes wandering back over and I was like
oh this is my son this is why and he's
like dead I just peed in the indoor tree
okay needless to say it didn't work out
we're not we're not going it up not
going to that school not happening for
us
you